- [Instructor] So I have data here
on two different websites,
website A and website B.
And my question to you is,
which one is more productive?
And some of you might be asking yourself,
what does it mean
to be productive?
And at a very high level,
you could view productivity
as how effective something
is at producing.
So for a given amount of input
into the process,
how much output are you getting?
If you want to get a
little bit more exact,
you could view it as the
rate of output per input.
But that still makes us ask the question,
what are the inputs and
what are the outputs?
So pause this video and think about
how you would measure productivity for or
how you would compare the productivity of
these two websites.
And there's multiple ways
to do it.
All right, now let's
think through it together.
What I'm first going to do
is look at each of these lines and think
about whether they are
an input or an output.
So the number of writers, well,
you need the writers
to produce the website.
So I would consider that an input.
Although if you were the head of HR,
the person who is hiring writers,
the head of human resources,
and you were hiring writers,
then that could actually be an output.
But if we're just thinking
about creating a website,
we need writers to create
it so that's an input.
Number of posts posted,
average number of words of post,
average likes of post,
average comments of post,
number of new subscribers,
those all feel like outputs.
If the writers do a good job,
they're going to produce a lot of posts,
they're going to, I guess,
have a lot of words,
I don't know if it's good
to always be wordy.
People will like their posts,
they'll comment on those posts.
We'll have new subscribers.
So this is all output.
What about revenue?
That's how much money a site brings
in before having to pay its expenses.
So that also should be an output
because if the writers do a good job,
if the site is well run,
they will generate a lot of revenue.
What about expenses?
Well, you need to use expenses.
You need to spend expenses on
things like writer salaries in
order to create your website,
in order to generate that revenue.
So I would consider that an input.
And what about profit?
Profit is all the money you bring in
minus your expenses and
how much you get leftover.
Well,
some people would argue the
whole point of a business
is to generate that profit.
That is an outcome you want
to maximize, an output.
And so I would consider that an output.
And so the question of
productivity really just boils down
to which output or what combinations
of output do we want
to figure out the rate
that we're generating
relative to some input or
some combination of inputs?
So a really simple way
of measuring productivity
in this situation,
let's define it, productivity.
And once again,
there's multiple ways of defining it.
Let's say it is equal
to the profit per number of writers.
So it could be profit over
the number of writers.
If we define it that way,
which website is more productive?
Well, website A,
in that definition,
A would have a productivity
of $10,000 for five writers.
So it would be $2,000 profit per writer.
And what would be B's per
activity by this definition?
Well, $28,000 divided by 11,
28,000 divided by 11 writers,
there's $28,000 in profit.
That gives us a 2,000,
and we'll round, 2,545.
So approximately $2,545
of profit per writer.
So based on this
measurement of productivity,
it looks like website B
is more productive.
Now what if we did maybe
even a simpler one,
or maybe one that you might think
is even more natural?
What if we thought about it as the number
of posts per writer?
So let's do it that way.
So if we just defined productivity,
I'll just do that,
as being equal to the number
of posts divided by the writers.
Well, in this situation,
website A would have a productivity
of 110 divided by five,
which would be 22,
22 posts per writer,
and website B 200 divided by 11 ,
200 divided by 11 gets us,
well, we could just
round that to maybe 18,
since we want to get rough estimates,
to 18 posts per writer.
So by this measure of productivity,
website A actually looks more productive.
So hopefully this gives
you just a general sense
of what productivity is,
and an appreciation that
there's multiple ways
of measuring it.
And you could do much fancier things,
you could say,
you could make it a whole combination
of outputs divided by a
combination of inputs.
So you could define
productivity as the number
of posts posted times the
average number of posts,
you take that quantity,
and then maybe add the
average likes per post
or multiply by the average likes per post,
and then add to that the comments per post
or multiply by the comments per post
and then divide by the number of writers
or the number of writers and expenses
or divide just by the expenses.
But the general notion is you
wanna take some combination
of the outputs,
maybe even just one
output and divide it by
some combination of the inputs
and you can actually decide
how you even wanna combine,
how you wanna mathematically combine
those outputs and inputs.